[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne
gellineck guten Abend wir haben ja in
den letzten Wochen des hängens und
würgens um den Bundeshaushalt einige
neue Vokabeln gelernt Jährlichkeit
igkeit Fälligkeit heute ist nun noch
eine dazu gekommen vorläufige
Haushaltsführung die vorläufige
Haushaltsführung nämlich greift wenn es
zum 1 januar eines Jahres keinen
gesetzlich beschlossenen Haushalt gibt
genau das scheint der Fall zu sein denn
die chefverhandler der drei
ampelparteien haben sich noch nicht
geeinigt und reißen damit alle Fristen
für die noch notwendigen
parlamentarischen Verfahren bis zum
Jahresende der FDP Finanzminister gibt
sich entspannt SPD und Grüne betonen sie
könnten keine falschen Kompromisse
schließen und die Opposition lehnt sich
grinsend zurück Andreas küast aus
Berlin der Tag beginnt schon ziemlich
genervt und wird danach nicht besser
werden bevor der Bundesrat an diesem
Morgen dem Nachtragshaushalt für dieses
Jahr zustimmt bekommt die
Bundesregierung eine geklebt weil auf
den Haushalt für nächstes Jahr die
Bürger die Wirtschaft und die
Bundesländer Hände Ringen warten würden
es ist eine schwierige Lage das will ich
anerkennen aber es wird auch Zeit dass
die ampelregierung jetzt ihren Vorschlag
vorliegt für 2024 damit die Zeit der
Unruhe der Unsicherheit vorbei ist es
war der Kanzler selbst der die Erwartung
erhöht hat dass die Zeit der
Unsicherheit nicht nur zügig sondern
sehr sehr zügig vorbei sei die
ampelverhandle so Scholz am Montag sehr
konstruktiv und das geht ja nur wenn man
Dinge die schwierig sind schnell
entscheiden zu entscheiden in der Lage
ist und mein Eindruck ist diese
Bereitschaft existiert dass diese
Bereitschaft dann doch nicht existiert
dass es Scholz dass es die Ampel nicht
schafft sich rechtzeitig zu einigen wird
in den Zeitungen von morgen
erbarmungslos kommentiert das Bild dass
die ampelregierung abgibt ist
erschreckend eine glatte sech beim
Regieren durchgefallen Bankrotterklärung
der scholzregierung darf ich sie ganz
kurz daran erinnern wo wir gerade sind
ich weiß ich weiß
Brüssel nicht in Berlin der Tag begann
genervt und geht genervt weiter in
Brüssel Nerven die Journalisten
Finanzminister Lindner der keine Krise
sehen will und keinen Grund zur
Aufregung der Staat ist vollkommen
handlungsfähig es wird keine Behörde
schließen es wird kein Gehalt nicht
ausgezahlt es wird niemand der ein
Unterstützungsleistung erwartet sie
nicht erhalten aus der SPD die morgen
ihren parteit beginnt kommt derart
kämpferisch vorgetragene Unterstützung
für Olaf Scholz dass jeder merkt woran
es in den ampelgesprächen gehagt hat
dass Sozialdemokraten niemals ihre Hand
für sozialstaatsabbau in Deutschland
heben werden oder dafür dass wir nicht
mehr in unsere Zukunft investieren da
weiß er ob mit oder ohne Parteitag die
gesamte Partei hinter sich heute vor
genau zi Jahren hat die Ampel ihren
Koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben heute
sagt die Union es ist
vorbei die Ampel blamiert nicht sich
selbst die blamiert das ganze Land Olaf
Scholz ist der Erfinder dieses
haushaltstricks er ist gescheitert er
trägt die Schuld und deswegen werden
jetzt neuwahen der sauberste Weg der Tag
begann genervt und er ist noch nicht zu
Ende als die SPD am Abend zu ihrem
traditionellen vorwärts parteitagsfest
zusammenkommt warnt sie vor schlechten
Kompromissen die FDP die Grünen und sich
selbst fragen wir noch mal nach bei
unserer hauptstadtkorrespondentin Diana
zimmermann J Neuwahlen und schlechte
Kompromisse aber Olaf Scholz erweckt ja
immer noch den Eindruck dass die
Einigung unmittelbar bevorstehe woran
hakt es denn
noch ja diesen Eindruck erweckt der
Kanzler gern und versucht es auch jetzt
noch da eigentlich offenkundig ist dass
das nicht funktioniert es hakt im Grunde
genommen an dem gründungsversprechen der
selbsternannten fortschrittskoalition
einfach weil die drei Parteien dieser
Koalition sehr unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen davon haben was
Fortschritt ist und unter dem akuten
Geldmangel der hier herrscht bricht das
jetzt als Verteilungskampf im Kanzleramt
auf Scholz Lindner und habbeck werden
sich morgen hier wieder Zusammentreffen
setzen und dann geht es weiterhin so
hören wir um Steuererhöhungen um
Einsparungen und auch darum eventuell
doch noch mal eine Notfallsituation zu
erklären die Begründung wäre der
ukrainekrieg und das würde dazu dienen
die schultenbremse noch einmal zu
umgehen tatsächlich soll dieser Zustand
spätestens so sagen sie Ende Januar
beendet sein bis dahin will man dann
eine Einigung haben und sie ganz regulär
durch den Bundestag und den Bundesrat
gebracht haben und bis dahin gilt die
vorläufige Haushaltsführung also was
bedeutet das jetzt ganz praktisch für
Deutschland also ganz praktisch bedeutet
es Christian ninden hat ja auch eben im
Beitrag schon gesagt dass alle Gehälter
des Bundes gezahlt werden dass die
Sozialleistungen gezahlt werden es
bedeutet auch dass bewilligte
Förderanträge z.B für unternehmenskredit
und so weiter das alles wird gezahlt
aber viele Anträge sind noch in der
Bearbeitung es ist auch nicht klar
welche Förderprogramme nächstes Jahr
aufgelegt werden und das bedeutet für
viele Bürger und vor allen Dingen für
viele Unternehmen eine große
Unsicherheit und eine Unruhe das
manifestiert sich sehr stark im Osten wo
Milliarden schwere Investitionen etwa in
die hbliterindustrie erwartet werden und
man nicht weiß wie es da nun weitergeht
immerhin ist es so dass die Ampel sagt
sie wolle sich einigen es gebe weiterhin
den Willen sich zu einigen ähm
allerdings braucht es eben erstmal
zumindest die Einigung der drei
Spitzenkräfte dann einen
Kabinettsbeschluss und auf die Einigung
warten wir ja und bekommen sie auch
schon seit einigen Tagen versprochen
Prinzip Hoffnung also weiter danke Diana
Zimmermann war das aus unserem
Hauptstadtstudio guten Abend nach
Berlin es gibt auch Dinge die die
Bundesregierung überraschend schnell auf
den Weg bringt seit heute nämlich kann
man sich in Deutschland wieder am
Telefon krank schreiben lassen sie
erinnern sich das gab es schon mal
während der coronapandemie und auch
jetzt ist die Corona und Erkältungswelle
wieder so angeschwollen dass die
Arztpraxen rappelvoll sind und schwups
belebte die Regierung die alte Regelung
wieder und zwar für immer die Ärzte sind
erleichtert der Verband der Arbeitgeber
fürchtet dagegen dass so die
Krankschreibung entwertet werde unter
welchen Bedingungen eine telefondiagnose
möglich ist weiß Roman
leskowa Wolfgang Kreischer hat momentan
alle Hände voll zu tun die
Infektionswelle spürt der Berliner
Allgemeinmediziner seit Wochen auch bei
Kollegen sei es kaum anders so früh in
der Erkältungssaison ist es eine
ungewöhnliche Lage es sind mehrere
Wellen die sich zur Zeit überlappen das
ist einmal eine Grippewelle einmal eine
coronawelle und dann normale
Erkältungskrankheiten da gehört auch das
RSV dazu das ist ein Virus was den
Verdau was den t befällt und heftige
erkältungserscheinung hervorruft in der
Pandemie war für den Hausarzt noch die
telefonische Krankschreibung möglich die
extra geschaffene Regelung lief im März
allerdings aus jetzt mitten in der
Infektionswelle müssen die Patienten
wieder in die Praxis kommen für ihn hat
sich die Regelung damals bewährt 80% der
Corona infizierten konnten zu Hause
bleiben die Praxen wurden ja
freigehalten von infizierten Patienten
das heißt sonst werden die Praxen
möglicherweise zu Hotspots GEW geworden
und man wä in der Praxis krank geworden
als Patient das geringere
Ansteckungsrisiko für Mitarbeiter und
Patienten das eine die Entlastung der
Mediziner das andere gerade deshalb
haben die Ärzteverbände Druck gemacht
damit die Regelung zurückkehrt heute hat
der Gemeinsame Bundesausschuss die
konkreten Details festgelegt das
wichtigste sicher die telefonische
Krankschreibung soll ab sofort gelten
Ärzte können maximal 5 Tage per
telefonrank schreiben und die Regelung
gilt nur für Patienten die in der Praxis
bereits bekannt sind wir haben das nicht
eingeschränkt auf bestimmte Erkrankungen
das ist auch ein Unterschied zur
damaligen Sonderregelung in der
coronazeit die einzige Einschränkung ist
dass es absehbar leichtere Verläufe des
Krankheitsbildes sein müssen kritik
kommt von den Arbeitgebern per Telefon
drohten womöglich mehr Krankschreibungen
so die Befürchtung was mehr Arbeit für
die nichtkranken Kollegen bedeute das
könnte Unruhe stiften mit der
telefonischen Krankschreibung gibt es
auch Rückfragen aus der Belegschaft auch
an die Unternehmensleitung ob das denn
alles so mit rechten Dingen zugeht das
haben wir zur Kenntnis zu nehmen und
unsere Sorge ist dass es den
Betriebsfrieden herausfordert auch
Wolfgang Kreischer kann schwarze Schafe
nicht gänzlich ausschließen deshalb
betont er gelte die Regelung nur für
praxisbekannte Patienten am Ende wird es
also an den Ärzten liegen Vorbehalte
wegen der telefonischen Krankschreibung
auszuräumen es ist fast 5 Jahre her dass
die Spitzen der EU und die der
chinesischen Staatsführung einander
leibhaftig gegenübaßen und die
Wiedersehensfreude ist begrenzt die
Europäer verstört dass China den
russischen Angriffskrieg nicht nur nicht
verurteilt sondern sogar unterstützt
Peking kauft weiterhin russisches Öl und
Gas und liefert Moskau kriegsrelevante
Hightech Güter wie z.B Speicherchip
noch schlimmer es rumpelt bei den
europäischchinesischen
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen China importiert
viel mehr waren in die EU als umgekehrt
darunter neuerdings auch staatlich
subventionierte und deshalb sehr billige
Elektroautos und Windräder über einen
Dialog zwischen Annäherung und
Abschottung berichtet Miriam Steimer aus
Peking was hier liegt ist Teil des
Problems zwischen China und der EU das
sehen z die euvertreter so die heute
nach Peking gekommen sind doch von vorne
nach Jahren der coronapause ist es der
erste chinaeug Gipfel in Präsenz und
mitgebracht haben die Europäer Kritik an
einem großen
Ungleichgewicht denn China verkauft viel
mehr waren nach Europa als es umgekehrt
waren aus Europa kauft laut euangaben
betrug das Handelsdefizit zuletzt fast
400 Milliarden
Euro
die Ursachen sind bekannt und wir haben
sie diskutiert sie reichen vom
mangelnden Zugang europäischer
Unternehmen zum chinesischen Markt über
die Bevorzugung einheimischer
chinesischer Unternehmen bis hin zu
Überkapazitäten in der chinesischen
Produktion
Überkapazitäten z.B an Windturbinen von
den 15 größten Herstellern stammen
inzwischen neun aus China und unter
bieten die Preise der europäischen
Wettbewerber Jörg Wutke weiß um dieses
Problem hat die EU vor ihrem Treffen
beraten denn kaum ein deutscher kennt
die Volksrepublik so gut wie der
ehemalige Präsident der Europäischen
Handelskammer in China seit 30 Jahren
lebt er
hier China z.B hat 40% mehr Windturbinen
hergestellt und nicht eine Firma macht
Profit nicht einer ja also das wird
sicherlich auch ein Thema sein inwie
weit diese Überkapazitäten jetzt durch
dieses exportventil durchgehen und die
Weltmärkte rausgehen weil eben hier der
konsumark liegt denn Chinas Wirtschaft
schwächelt auch deshalb hört sich die
Staatsführung die problemliste der EU
heute an z.B die wiederholte
Aufforderung dass Peking seinen Einfluss
auf Russland nutzen soll um den Krieg in
der Ukraine zu beenden doch die
chinesische Staatsführung nutzt weiter
die Argumente des Kremmel steht an
Russlands Seite solange das der
Volksrepublik nutzt verkauft sich in der
Propaganda gerne als Schlichter
China glaubt ja nur sie wären neutral
aber sind natürlich neutral russisch
positiv ja und das das ist natürlich
klar erkennbar dass es sich
eigentlich statt auf Konfliktthemen
einzugehen betont die chinesische Seite
heute die
Gemeinsamkeiten die Beziehungen zwischen
der EU und China sind dabei sich stabil
und gut zu entwickeln was den Interessen
beider Seiten
entspricht China braucht die
Zusammenarbeit braucht den europäischen
Absatzmarkt um seine Wirtschaft wieder
Schwung zu bringen und auch die Europäer
brauchen
China und hier geht's jetzt weiter mit
Heinz Wolf und dem nächsten Bahnstreik
der vor einer Viertelstunde begonnen hat
ja die GDL die Gewerkschaft deutscher
Lokomotivführer hatte dazu aufgerufen ab
22 Uhr im Personenverkehr und schon ab
18 Uhr im Güterverkehr die Bahn Namen
bereits am frühen Abend erste
Fernverbindungen aus dem Angebot und
sprach von einer massiven
Beeinträchtigung wegen des GDL Streik
enden soll der Streik laut GDL in knapp
24 Stunden morgen um 22
Uhr im Tarifstreit des öffentlichen
Dienstes der Länder wird seit heute
wieder verhandelt für die dritte und
womöglich entscheidende Gesprächsrunde
in Potzdam haben die Arbeitgeber ein
Angebot angekündigt es soll sich am
Abschluss für den öffentlichen Dienst
von Bund und Kommunen orientieren die
Gewerkschaft werde und der Beamtenbund
fordern
10,5% mehr Lohn mit mindestens aber 500
€ mehr wofür es in den vergangenen
Wochen mehrfach Warnstreiks
gab seit Griechenland im Februar dieses
Jahres der Türkei nach einem schweren
Erdbeben zu Hilfe kam haben sich die
lange angespannten Beziehungen zwischen
den beiden Ländern verbessert und heute
gab es dann ein Treffen des griechischen
Regierungschefs mitzotakis und des
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan dabei
wurde laut mitsotakis seine erklär der
guten Nachbarschaft unterzeichnet und
Zusammenarbeit in verschiedenen
Bereichen
vereinbart die internationale Militär
und Finanzhilfe für die Ukraine ist in
den vergangenen Monaten stark
zurückgegangen sie betrage nach Angaben
des Instituts für Weltwirtschaft in Kiel
nur noch etwas mehr als 10% des
Vorjahreszeitraums der wichtigste
Unterstützer sind die USA die
oppositionellen Republikaner haben im
ussenat neue Milliarden schwere
sicherheitshilfen für die Ukraine und
Israel vorerst blockiert sie fordern
eine strengere
Einwanderungspolitik Präsident Biden
sagt er sei zu großen Kompromissen
bereit eines der wichtigsten jüdischen
Feste das Lichterfest hanuka hat mit dem
Entzünden des ersten Lichts an den
traditionellen hanuka Leuchtern begonnen
Bundeskanzler Scholz der zum ersten Mal
an der Feier vor dem Brandenburger Tor
teilnahm rief zu Solidarität und
Mitgefühl für die Jüdinnen und Juden in
Deutschland auf bei dem achttägigen fest
treffen sich die Gläubigen nach Einbruch
der Dunkelheit vor allem mit Familie und
Freunden und zünden jeden Tag ein neues
Licht am hanukaleuchter
an und wir schauen nach Israel das
Verhältnis zwischen dem jüdischen Staat
und den Vereinten Nationen ist schon
seit langem angespannt die Mehrheit der
UN-Mitgliedstaaten sympathisiert mit der
Sache der palä enser und verurteilt
Israel regelmäßig vor diesem Hintergrund
verwundert es nicht dass auch die UN
Frauenorganisation nach dem Überfall auf
Israel ganze 8 Wochen brauchte um einen
dürren Satz zur sexuellen Gewalt von
Hamas Terroristen gegen Frauen und
Mädchen zu formulieren dieser Teil des
systematischen
hamasterrors Spiele in der
internationalen Wahrnehmung so gut wie
keine Rolle kritisieren israelische
Frauenrechtlerinnen dabei ist gerade die
Anerkennung von traumatischen
Erfahrungen ein wichtiger Schritt zur
Verarbeitung Henriette deisier
berichtet Bilder die so ungeheuerlich
sind dass wir nur ausgewählte zeigen
können Berichte die an Grausamkeit
unsere Vorstellungskraft übersteigen
Augenzeugen deren Erzählungen den
Schrecken nur erahnen
lassen die ganze Zeit die wir hier in
der Kuhle versteckt lagen haben wir
Mädchen gehört wir haben gehört wie die
Täter sich um die Frauen gestritten
haben ich hörte auch wie sie um die
Genugtung stritten wer wen zuerst
umbringt hunderte Leichen die Asche von
bei lebendigem Leib verbrannten Babys
abgetrennte Gliedmaßen Überreste
menschlichen Lebens die jüdische
Religion gebietet eine rasche Beerdigung
für genaue Ermittlungsarbeit blieb kaum
Zeit Beweise für Vergewaltigungen mit
den Opfern
begraben unsere Kriminalbeamten die sich
die Opfer ansahen während sie
Fingerabdrücke und DNA Aufnahmen sahen
das sie sahen Enthauptungen
Verstümmelung sie sahen Schüsse
nahschüsse und sie sahen
fesseln das schänden von Frauenkörpern
als Kriegswaffe eine junge Frau die als
Geisel genommen wird mit sichtbaren
Verletzungen die Last der Bilder
erdrückend doch
unzeigbar die Hamas Terroristen hatten
bodykameras bei sich die Sie vorbereitet
hatten und sie filmten all die gruetaten
die sie begingen in
Echtzeit sie gingen sogar in die Social
Media Accounts ihrer Opfer und posteten
alles ein auf der Plattform x
veröffentlichtes Video
islamistische Propaganda welche sexuelle
grultaten legitimieren soll die
Beweislast scheint erdrückend und doch
gibt es den berechtigten Vorwurf
israelische Frauenrechtlerinnen dass die
Taten lange ignoriert
wurden die un-gräien unfraauen alle
internationalen
Frauenrechtsorganisationen haben sich
entschieden die von der Hamas begangene
sexuelle Gewalt nicht
anzusprechen erst vor einigen Tagen
knapp 8 Wochen nach dem 7 Oktober nach
heftiger Kritik und Protesten eine
Stellungnahme der un-frauen man
verurteile den Angriff der Hamas sei
alarmiert über die Berichte von
sexueller Gewalt und fordere Aufklärung
die UN-Kommission für Kriegsverbrechen
kündigte an sich spezifisch auf diese
Taten zu
konzentrieren Kriege haben viele
Schlachtfelder und werden immer wieder
auch auf den Körpern von Frauen
ausgetragen
und wir machen einen harten Schnitt und
jetzt weiter mit den Nachrichten aus
Sport und Wirtschaft und mit Heinz Wolf
Verbraucherschutzministerin Lempke hat
angekündigt dass die Koalition zeitnah
Regelungen prüfen werde die die
Transparenz verbessern beim sogenannten
scoring also einer Form der
Kreditwürdigkeitsprüfung sie reagierte
damit auf eine Entscheidung des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs heute Sina
mein was konkret hat der GH da
entschieden er hat für die Verwendung
des schuf enge Grenzen gesetzt zwar
dürfen Firmen ihn nutzen um damit eben
die Kreditwürdigkeit von Kundinnen und
Kunden zu hinterfragen und eben zu
entscheiden ob Sie beispielsweise einen
Kredit vergeben sie dürfen ihn aber
nicht als alleinige
Entscheidungsgrundlage nutzen denn wenn
dieser Wert die maßgebliche Rolle bei
der Kreditvergabe spielt stellt das eine
automatisierte Entscheidung im
Einzelfall da und diese ist nach der
datenschutzgrundverordnung verboten rund
68 Millionen Menschen sind bei der
Schufa gelistet mit diesen Daten wird
durch mathematisch statistische
Verfahren ein Wahrscheinlichkeitswert
ermittelt der sogenannte Scorewert
dieser bestimmt wie kreditwürdig man ist
wichtig z.B für Banken oder
Vermieter Verbraucherschützer begrüßen
dieses Urteil die schufer müssen nun
verantwortungsvoller mit ihrer quasi
Monopolstellung umgehen heißt es und
noch zum DAX da ging es mit der
Rekordjagd heute erstmal nicht weiter so
ist es aber nach sieben Gewinntagen inf
Folge und einem erneuten Allzeithoch
gestern ist solch eine Verschnaufpause
am Aktienmarkt wohl auch ganz gesund
seit Jahresbeginn hat der DAX fast 20%
zugelegt und diese jüngste Rekordjagd
war einigen jetzt wohl doch nicht mehr
so ganz geheuer leichte Abschläge also
heute am Ende aber dennoch ein Stand der
sich sehen lassen kann
16629 Punkte Konjunkturoptimismus eine
rückläufige Inflation in der Eurozone
und die Aussicht auf wieder sinkende
Zinsen sind derzeit in den Kursen schon
eingepreist ein leichter Dämpfer kann
also heute keinen wirklich überraschen
Sina meinitz vielen Dank neue DFB
sportdirektorin für die Frauen wird nia
Künzer das gab der Deutsche Fußballbund
heute bekannt die 3-jährige
exweltmeisterin tritt den neueschaffenen
Posten am 1 Januar an bei der Handball
WM in Skandinavien haben die deutschen
Frauen heute das Spiel gegen Rumänien
gewonnen und damit einen großen Schritt
in Richtung Viertelfinale gemacht es war
eine hart umkämpfte Partie die das
deutsche Frauenteam knapp mit 24 Z2 23
für sich entscheiden konnte vor allem
durch eine überragende Leistung der
Torfrau Katarina Filter die 16 Würfe der
rumäninen abwehren konnte am Samstag
wird das deutsche Team gegen Serbien
spielen und wäre bei einem weiteren Sieg
sicher für das WM Viertelfinale
qualifiziert es steht nicht alles still
in Deutschland das ist die gute
Nachricht zum Schluss es gibt sie noch
die ganz großen Verkehrsprojekte auf der
ostseinsel femarn fiel heute der
Startschuss für eine Bahnstrecke die von
Lübeck nach puttgarten eben auf femarn
führen soll sie dient als Anbindung für
den Tunnel der dann unter der Ostsee
nach Dänemark weiterführen soll und
schon im Bau ist klar Genehmigungen
dauerten viel länger als in Dänemark und
die sind auch noch längst nicht für alle
Bauabschnitte erteilt natürlich hat das
Projekt viele Gegner und logisch wurde
es auch in den Haushaltsverhandlungen
der letzten Wochen noch mal in Frage
gestellt Kosten immerhin 3,5 Milliarden
aber heute hieß es dann doch das sei gut
angelegtes Geld des Bundes und die
Finanzierung damit gesichert Henner
Hebestreit berichtet von der Insel
femann Kleiderbügel nennen sie auf
feemann die Brücke die ihre Insel seit
über 60 Jahren mit dem Festland
verbindet für Autos und Eisenbahnen ist
das Konstrukt über den femnund errichtet
worden um sie herum beginnt die Bahn
jetzt mit groß
[Musik]
Bauarbeiten schon bei diesem Festakt
muss die Bahn improvisieren eigentlich
wollten sie dort wo sie schon ein
bisschen bauen zünmftig die Sparten in
die femeraner Erde stechen doch das
Tauwetter hatte alles in eine
Schlammlandschaft verwandelt trotzdem
große Freude dass es nach langem
juristischen Streit endlich
losgeht wir haben mit den Bürgerinnen
Bürgern diskutiert und sind zu Lösung
gekommen sind vielleicht nicht immer
alle mit allem ganz einverstanden aber
dass es heute losgehen kann ist wichtig
und auch wichtig für den
Eisenbahnverkehr in Europa denn für die
firmanbtquerung baut Dänemark für gut 7
Milliarden Euro einen Tunnel durch die
Ostsee knapp 90 solcher Betonelemente
werden auf der 18 km lange Distanz im
Meer versenkt mit Röhren für den Auto
und
Eisenbahnverkehr damit es auf der
deutschen Seite hinter dem Tunnel zügig
weitergeht verlegt die Bahn zwischen
Puttgarden und Lübeck auf 85 km neue
Schienen oder modernisiert vorhandene
Trassen dieses Bahnprojekt schließt
einmal die Lücke im
Hochgeschwindigkeitsnetz zwischen
Skandinavien und Mitteleuropa auch
Norddeutschland soll davon
profitieren das ist immer auch eine
Chance genau für die Region hier durch
eine gute Anbindung auch durch
Gewerbeflächen die wir entwickeln hier
werden viele Arbeitsplätze zusätzlich
entstehen und deswegen wird die gesamte
Region auch davon profitieren auf femn
gab es stets Vorbehalte gegen den
Tunnelbau Bürgerinitiativen wie
Weltretter protestierten aus Sorge um
die Natur oder aus Angst als Urlaubsziel
unattraktiv zu werden konnten sich vor
Gericht aber nicht durchsetzen ich habe
immer gesagt wir wollen dieses Projekt
verhindern und nach dem Richterspruch
war das dann eindeutig eben nicht mehr
zu verhindern und dann ist man als guter
Demokrat auch bereit sein Frieden damit
zu machen die Bahn muss sich jetzt
beeilen in SE Jahren schon sollen
Hochgeschwindigkeitszüge die Fahrzeit
von Hamburg nach Kopenhagen en wird ihr
eigener Tunnel zwischen femann und dem
Festland nicht rechtzeitig fertig müssen
sie noch mal
improvisieren und die ICEs über den
Kleiderbügel
schleichen und die Bahn muss sich
beeilen das war's von uns wir empfehlen
Ihnen jetzt bei malbr ilner
vorbeizuschauen sie hat heute neben den
Generalsekretären von SPD und CDU Sarah
Wagenknecht zu Gast und diskutiert zum
Thema notop am Haushalt wen macht die am
und um 045 meldet sich den Christopher
wermann mit unserem heute journal Update
tschüss schönen Abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend Udo heißt das
Tief dessen eindrucksvolle wolkenspirale
die hier westlich von Großbritannien
sehen dieses Tief das ich da heute
eingekringelt hat bringt Regen mit und
wenn der auf den gefrorenen Boden fällt
dann wird es Spiegel glatt das geht
jetzt in diesen Stunden los und
pünktlich zum Berufsverkehr sollten Sie
also in einem Streifen vom emsern bis
zum Schwarzwald mit Eisregen rechnen im
Osten wird die Nacht noch ruhig sein da
ist es mal mehr mal weniger stark
bewölkt und zum Teil auch neblig meist
sinken die Temperaturen in den Frost und
am kältesten wird's hier Richtung
kiemgau mit -11° im Westen macht sie
schon die etwas mildere Luft bemerkbar
mit + 1° am niederheim Glatteisregen
Schnee und Schneeregen ziehen dann
morgen im Laufe des Tages weiter
ostwärts und besonders gefährlich durch
Eisregen wird es morgen über Tag wohl in
Teilen von Hessen Thüringen und Bayern
werden im Westen wird dann ganz bald
Regen aus dem Eisregen und westlich des
Rheins lässt dieser Regen auch nach dort
wird es schon recht mild die
Temperaturen steigen auf 6 bis 8° ein
Rest der Frostluft hält sich aber morgen
noch im östlichen Bayern da liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen so bei
-2-1° und in den nächsten Tagen geht es
windig mild und regnerisch weiter am
Montag liegen die Höchsttemperaturen bei
6 bis 13°. diese Milderung ist
allerdings nur von kurzer Dauer wie sie
hier am Beispiel von Berlin sehen können
denn schon zum Ende der nächsten Woche
wird es wieder kälter guten
Abend